[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
especially your experience what are the
changer you're getting from his
experience in Spain which was unexpected
the salaam-alaikum greatest peace peace
be with you
[Music]
[Music]
so we don't maybe some of us will forgot
how this all journey started like now
we're talking about millions of viewers
including on the same channel many other
channels are putting your show so we
will take it for granted you've been
with us doing this show weekly on Friday
but really from the chase strong desire
to want to amass all of the things of
dunya and then you have those things and
then all that wings off it's not the
same thing you go through what we call
sometimes in America midlife crisis by
the now you're buying a Corvette right
and they're like you're getting older
you start asking what's the purpose of
life you start really pondering and
thinking and a hundred not
but I didn't want to go ahead and follow
blindly so I wanted to make sure that
this way of life was from the Creator
and you know how it goes you go all
around the world you start looking at
all the world religions you investigate
you do with a smart intelligent pursuit
does and you connect with your crater
guiding you along the way you have su
sincerely ask guide me what's the
purpose why am ia lungs clear stand off
of all the rest provides all of the
logical rational evidences proves that
indeed is from the crater of the heavens
in a hearth and then naturally I wasn't
even nobody was telling you got to get
down with nobody but it was a natural
consequence I was learning I was getting
excited I'm like wow this stuff works
he's doing something for me if now you
care about your friends and your family
and it was just a natural result
it's very important and and we know when
the prophets also made the dua for the
two hormones right because he knew the
power the influence that they have
nowadays usually the youth and the
adults people who are taking the wrong
examples as role models so when you for
instance you have Zayn Malik for
instance okay or NAS these are the
recent shows we did and from there a
catcher cat captures the audience's
attention to see not necessarily we're
sending them a message with love at the
same time but their audience also
they're their fans so they tune in say
what are they talking about - what are
they talking about my so injera and now
not only is this a seed planet that if
Allah wants to deliver aid it gets to
them but at the same time their mass
following and the Muslims also who
normally wouldn't tune it now they can
tune in and see they can benefit from
these gems that the guests have on that
we talk about do you
so you see that that's the type of thing
we want to ask you what what do you see
it in the future you've been doing that
for 12 years you're going to continue
for sure but where do you want to take
it further
GPS is I always say gentlemen okay so we
just got an itch all on stay with it and
do our small part everybody its if
everybody can do because obviously a
lost want all of the crater that I was
an earth he's not going to judge us on
the results
it's our effort that we put in this is a
beautiful story about the rock that
committed suicide hear that story about
the rock that committed suicide small
little rock holding up a huge dam with
all these other rocks so when people
everyone contributes their small part
everybody doesn't have to be on TV
doesn't have to be a speaker to them but
if everybody people behind the scenes
everybody contributes because if
everybody stops contributing and those
small little rocks for instance what
happened with the rock the rock is
helping to hold up the dam he didn't see
his significance he's so small so he
committed suicide he jumped in the water
in the river and then what happened that
rock came out of its place and every
other walk started falling down and then
the dam collapsed now imagine yourself
is that Little Rock everyone all of us
in unison is working together in harmony
one ummah doing what the prophet saw
some his sunnah and the sunnah the way
of all the messengers of allah conveying
this message in behavior and attitude
and in speech in the best of action then
we're going to collectively make a huge
impact
final question you know like how hard
being Dawa you might sue energy because
we do there are people think oh we doing
bad for the normalcy what we're doing
but deep inside how does it move you you
as a Muslim as a human being how is its
influence in your life and making you
steadfast in the demon Allah but this is
a great brilliant question because when
you're doing the download this is
something that not only obviously you're
trying to help others but first and
foremost when I press record I'm
benefiting myself I'm benefiting from
the knowledge that the person has to
share so that is because over the years
it's amazing the more I've interviewed
the chefs the Muftis who come over I not
literally mostly in shape from other
religions you know the top scholars the
more they gross themselves into the way
of life they're apart the more they saw
the contradictions the discrepancies the
more I push them away now they came to
Islam the more you study learn Islam and
you grow from it you to you use the
tools that it gives you for life to get
through the struggles to get through all
the challenges it empowers you
yeah but if we're not learning it we're
not living it and we're not sharing it
[Music]
how can you love someone if you don't do
what it does and it's something we have
to
like we have to understand that being a
Muslim is not just by name from our
parents is to me following the
leadership father is a busy loving is
there's a hadith where the prophet
sallallahu alayhi wa some the last and
final messenger sent to mankind when you
automatically when you accept him you
automatically include not exclude all
the preceding messages Jesus Moses
Abraham and all the ones that came
before with the same message worship the
Creator and not the creation he said he
was talking to all his companions
paraphrases the hadith and he said all
my followers were enter Jenna except
those who refused does anybody confused
here for the gem no no does everyone
everyone want to get to Jenna yes hello
husband but they said well who would
refuse Oh Messenger of Allah those that
don't follow my way my sinner in his way
and the way of all the prophets of Allah
was to convey this message
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so we got some brothers here one from
Turkey and you're from alpha from
Salford where's that and just around the
corner from here and you actually have a
unique story you accepted Islam hung on
the world oh that's a twenty several
years ago over over twenty years ago you
what was your background before Islam
well my my my father actually converted
to Islam but he died when I was quite
young so we were brought up with a kind
of bit of Islam in our lives and a bit
of everything so I went to Sunday school
we went
atheist kind of socialist youth camps
and things were your parents pushing by
a Jewish well my parents were Christian
originally but they both converted to
some by my father so we've had a kind of
reporter with awareness of Muslim there
weren't no you know pushing no we were
allowed to do what we won so we all kind
of went off our own ways and hand an
oval find our way back
what was it what was it that your
parents instilled in you what was it
that brought you back and you didn't
drift after let's see secularism - I was
I was an agnostic probably from about 13
to 20 on 121 is when I became a Muslim
yeah but what brought me back was the
whole process of a thought process
eventually and I think ultimately it
comes down to the issue of if there is
purpose in life then I can have purpose
if there's no purpose to existence then
my life is always just part of achieving
up yeah and if there's purpose then the
question is if anything ought to be the
case there ought to be justice and
justice cannot be limited to this life
yeah people died having led difficult
lives and suffered and people's I have
in there's life of ease and had
everything and done bad things and you
cannot have justice is limited to this
life so if there's purpose there's
justice there's justice then there must
be judgement there must be God there
must be
you know one God who can judge justly
one gun you found that that pure
monotheism that many people connect to
the purpose of life in Islam and you're
sharing Islam through this project that
you do what is that process the project
is called the public Quran campaign but
science with the crown in public praise
is for gold Lord of the Worlds
there you go if more people would read
the Quran connect the Quran you got a
beautiful project to help people connect
with the verbatim word of God the Quran
which tells you the purpose of life how
you got here why you're here where
you're going keeps it in Salaam alaikum
orange juice you made a nice straight
transition not a bar but a juice bar we
can go ahead and keep it clean all our
by alcohol free and when we drink
bismillah a loud bark
[Music]